joined this morning by y Council leader
Michael Vincent Mr Vincent thank you for
taking the time to join us this morning
thoughts
um it's obviously very sad that we're
three weeks on and Nicola hasn't been
found
our thoughts with the family
it's been a very difficult time for them
more than anybody and it's been quite
difficult for the people of St Michael's
as well obviously with all the intrusion
visitors and all the other horrific
things that have been going on around
the case so it's been it's been a very
difficult three weeks for many years
social media seems to have played quite
a role in this case definitely yes
um I mean you've spoken then about the
police being criticized
um all this investigation has been
conducted so so far in the public eye
everybody seems to have a theory on
social media everybody seems to want to
know all of the information we learned
yesterday obviously that the police
share of clearly more information with
the family but have been criticized
because they didn't then share more
information with the public than they
otherwise normally would so it's been
quite unprecedented I think in terms of
the interest in it I mean we're we're
here at the scene of a missing person
three weeks on from the day so I've
never known everything like it
um there's been a lot of criticism for
the police yeah where are you with that
I think that there are lessons to to be
learned but I think that they've done
their best and very difficult
circumstances would you be concerned
with that sort of information about one
of your loved ones being out in the
public Arena I wouldn't like it but as
we already know from the statement they
put out yesterday that was put out there
with the knowledge of people's family in
because other people were seeking to
make that information public and what
wasn't the police's decision of their
hand was forced should they have done it
again with the benefit of hindsight that
should be looked into for future cases
but I I think they've I think they have
done their best in very difficult
circumstances but if it was important to
the case should we not have known about
it earlier uh perhaps and that's that's
something that perhaps is fueled some of
the online speculation and some of the
interest in the in the story uh but
again I think that the police have done
what they could in difficulty my
surprise were you that they didn't
cordon off this area as a crime scene
potential crime scene
um
quite but it is quite difficult to
Corden up I suppose and been a public
footpath and being people coming and
going in the time between a bit of tape
around it perhaps yes uh again that's
that's something for them to look into
to learn some lessons from that how is
this community going to start to rebuild
from from what's Happening well the
community has stayed very strong it's a
very small place less than a thousand
people yeah indeed and they they've
rallied around they've they've been
incredibly strong for the family for the
children of the village and they've
carried on looking for Nicola in the
right way they've carried on trying to
raise awareness stood on the highway and
sort of held the pictures of her to try
and raise raise the memories of people
who perhaps have driven past on that day
so
um the community has stayed strong
um obviously finding Nicola would be
would be welcoming and helping to move
on from from this incident but
um I think the community has proved
myself to be very strong Community as
you know Sky News has been covering this
story throughout we decided to come up
today to we really focus on on what may
have happened and when you come and have
a look at this obviously I've been
talking about it for a long time it
looks pretty innocuous yes yes it does
um when the police first contacted the
council about it they didn't make clear
though that while the river looks very
calm on the surface it is quite strong
tidal current underneath so it does look
innocuous the river does look very calm
very peaceful but that's quite deceiving
and what other involvements have the
council had with the police have you
been able to help them and we've tried
to just raise awareness and try and get
the message out to people not to come to
St Michael's
um the local councilors have described
how busy this area has been at the
weekend there's been Lake Windermere on
a busy Summer's Day hundreds of people
and try to discourage people coming to
to somehow carry out their own
investigations which has been happening
and and just to try to stop some of the
more
darker elements of of the Public's
interest in this yeah people being
arrested for going into people's back
Gardens with flash torches at in the
middle of the night haven't you've seen
that there's no houses immediately
around here but Pete houses just nearby
people have reported being sat in their
living rooms in an afternoon watching
television and people coming up to the
windows peering in trying the doors it's
been terrifying for them there's a
typically elderly people
um extremely scared in their own homes
the residents have had to employ an
external security company that's just
not acceptable know that yeah okay and
how are they have you spoken to them
um the local councilors have kept in
regular touch with residents
um again the community have stayed
strong people typically stayed strong
and they've they've been very resilient
in these sort of difficult times and
that they do they have found it very
upsetting and very distressing do you
need to look at what you might need to
do to make this a safer place
uh possibly yes uh I think you think you
can always
um you can always learn lessons from
instance like this obviously the bank is
quite steep it's getting the balance
right though between what is potentially
one terrible incident and people's
access to the river and the ability to
walk into fish and and to do all the
things that they want to do on the
rivers but it is something you're going
to look at yes I mean we we aren't
necessarily responsible for would be
respect before fencing it off as a
Borough Council but we would wear with
Partners to look at what we can do
across the board to make The River Why
more safe for people yes it's good to
talk to you thanks for taking the time
to join us bear with me one second if
you would please thank you